the very astute among you will notice
that i never answered our original
question do you remember we started with
a question that sent us down this rabbit
hole and we got to the bottom of the
rabbit hole and we found something
so awesome in and of itself we were like
oh why did we end up here in the first
place why we ended up in the first place
here was
we're trying to get an answer to this
question right what on earth
like we know this is where we start with
indices and then we're like oh we can
expand this idea we can expand it we can
expand it and then you're like
what what i'll do with this okay we're
going to come up with an answer to this
question i'm going to show you how
for reasons to become clear in a second
i think it's just an easier
demonstration
i'm actually going to take a different
base instead of five i'm gonna deal with
two um you'll see why shortly how do we
get to there
from here i said this thing what do we
call it again has a name
you draw a big box around it right this
is euler's formula
euler's formula is like it's like
nuclear power it has this immense
capacity and potential to do lots of
different things with it it's also very
dangerous okay
so i'm going to use this euler's formula
as our bridge to get to
this guy okay for starters the first
thing that i noticed is
in the index here euler's formula is i
guess what we call very versatile you
can take
any x that you like right um any angle
that you like and you can pop it into
this formula so it's very
general right i don't need a really
general thing i actually have an id here
i don't know where that dot is over
there i just want
this guy here a specific index of i
so what value of x would i choose here
not a rhetorical question
that would get me just an index of i x
should equal
1 do you agree with that if i put in and
please write this with me right
if i put in x equals 1
i'm going to get on the right hand side
over here cos 1
plus i sine 1
okay now i know that looks strange
okay we're used to angles like 30
degrees or pi on three things like that
right
so we're not used to dealing with
radians remember
that just have numbers like this okay
but you could go to your calculator
right now if you're in radians mode and
you could work out what cos one
was it's like zero point what was it
0.56
and something like that it's just a
number okay so your calculator can deal
with this
this is e to the i in fact let's just go
ahead and let's evaluate that
zero point can you give me that number
again 0.5
five zero three did you say oh five four
so it's gonna round it's just gonna stay
to four is that okay i'll just get two
decimal places
can someone give me sine of 1 radian
what's that
0.84 so it's going to round to okay
there you go
so it's just some number right you're
like huh
uh seemingly strange and random but
from what we've just determined from
euler's formula it just works okay
now i'm still not quite at my answer
right like
e to the i but what about 2 to the power
of i so what i have to do here
is change base now i know exponentials
and logs
um dealing with them in a lot of detail
is something we haven't done for a while
so i'm going to refresh your memory okay
if you want to change base from
something like e to something like two
okay maybe you remember if i asked you
for something like this
right your calculator has uh two log
buttons one of them
is base e one of them's base ten why is
base ten by the way i don't know why
it's ten
why do we love ten engineering and
science
right have a look at the top of your
calculator it probably says there your
calculator is
not a mathematical calculator it's a
scientific calculator and scientific
notation
is all about base 10 okay so that's why
you've got a log base 10 button
you don't have a log base two buttons so
how do we turn this into something our
calculators can deal with
i'll give you a clue it's got one of
these in it
log of um a hundred and actually doesn't
matter what base you choose
so long as it's the same base log of 100
divided by log 2
and off you go so this is how you change
base in log land
now i will leave it as an exercise to
you to work out why exactly this this
will work out but
changing an exponential end basically
uses this trick but in reverse
okay if you wanted something like uh 2
but in base e what you would do is you
would say e
to the power of log 2.
i want you to think about why this works
right if you didn't know
what this thing was equal to right if
you said oh i don't know
let's let's just call it x right how
would you get at what was going on here
well hopefully what you might
instinctively do is take logs on both
sides
right which will give you this
like so is that okay i took logs of both
sides and then you've got a
a power up here that you can bring out
to the front so you get this
log to log e but what's what's this guy
over here
log base e of e is just one so therefore
you're getting log x equals log two so
you see x equals two is that okay
so i'm going to take advantage of the
fact that i can rewrite any number
with a base of e and therefore i can
take advantage of
this stuff up here so let's return to
this idea 2 to the power of i
i'm going to write 2 to the power of i
as
e to the log 2 to the power of i
so is that ok i'm just swapping this guy
for this guy right so i get
e to the i
how's that is that okay this thing is my
weird awkward way of writing
two even though it's so weird and
awkward though it helps me because i can
use something i
already know i'm just gonna do some
index laws on this right
is that okay see that now
by euler's formula i can say oh
that's the x that i'm putting in here do
you see that remember how we chose a
value of 1
up here for this well i'm not going to
choose one anymore what am i going to
choose
i'm going to be real careful right it's
actually this whole thing
here that's your x right
you see how it's the whole thing on the
end there so now what i want
is going to be as per euler's formula
cos of plus i sine
of what log 2 that's the thing
that you can see up there so reach for
your calculator
and go ahead and work out these two
things
did you get seven
seven and then point six
four from memory is that right okay
so here's one i prepared earlier that
right there am i in the right form sorry
just let me check
yeah there we go okay there don't move
there is to the power of i you're like
huh
what does that even mean why am i there
okay well i just want to show you real
quick and this is why i put it
up on the screen right what happens if
we have like a different
kind of i like a different imaginary
power up there what if we had 2 to the
power of
2i well look closely at where the number
goes watch watch closely
i'm just going to change it to 2.
you had 0.77 plus 0.64 i so it was
around
here and then for the next one i'm i'm
here
where might the next one go let me just
do one more and then i'm going to
animate it
let's do sorry about that weird stuff
there's three so this is to the power of
3i now so i was over here and then i was
here
what's happening how would you describe
the geometry of this
isn't this thing rotating
which kind of isn't that exactly what we
should have expected because way early
on we were like oh multiplying by i what
does it do
it rotates you around the complex pain
plane well complex pain all right right
exponentiation does something very
similar but in a fluid way it rotates
you
around the complex plane these are all
the different um
the order all the different powers 2 to
the power of i
2i 3i4 and it does this rotation around